citizens of the reject Nation it is John it is
Roxy stryer and together we are Ron joxie yes
nailed it we were debating beforehand what
our combined name should be if you like Ron
jaxi comment below but we are here today to
continue our blade Journey with easily the
most beloved blade film all of you have told
us it's your favorite and it's the best it's
Blade Trinity and we could not be more excited
to send this series off with a bang Roxy star
how you feeling I'm feeling nervous because
we loved blade one we love blade 2. I saw some
people in the comments saying Blade 3 actually
is underrated okay so I'ma hold on to that hope
absolutely I am too and you what you guys should
do is hold on to that like button hold on to that
subscribe and notification Bell let us know you're
enjoying these and what else you might want to see
next make sure to follow Roxy in the world
girls while you're clicking all those buttons
and last but not least as always if you want to
enjoy the full experience of Blade Trinity with
us everything that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com slash the
real rejects we got tons of awesome content over
there sync up with your own copy it is a blast and
without further Ado are you ready for blade born
ready to cut deep blade killing it roll the bumper
in the movies Dracula wears a cape and
some old English guy always manages to
save the day at the last minute with crosses
and holy water that's definitely Ryan Reynolds
yeah what did you know Ryan Reynolds
voice was about to pop up not at all
but you can recognize it a mile away even
when he's chill Deadpool introducing blade
dude maybe Wesley will show up and play
in uh Deadpool three that'd be dope oh
take that song yeah totally
F you son how dare you beam
structurally sound absolutely we should just go
right down in there it's cuneiform it's about 4
000 years old so why here because this
is the cradle of civilization whoa Parker
Posey there's something beneath us
you find a watch instead of body
[Music]
totally fair reaction not overreacting
whoa okay the strobe is intense
they're about to blow this rat up
now the rat's gonna Defuse The Bomb
oh it's like the sound that I can make yeah
to be a Foley artist you're welcome editors
cool as ever
wow how do you do that backward
because his instincts are so sharp
nice
whip knife this
what is Trinity that is that a
religious term like holy trinity
and goes there but it's any
you know Trio triumvirate
Etc but in this I mean I don't know we'll find out
[Music]
she's a really fast editing in this
movie what did we determine he's
shooting them with silver bullets is
that what's happening yeah I guess so
we'll get a montage of him filling shells
with silver buckshot nice the UV headlights
every time I see a car get destroyed in
a movie my heart hurts a little bit oh
I could drive that you could
just give it to me cars for kids
1877 cars for Roxy Strayer
so badass every time his face is
so still mistaken with silver why
don't you ask why aren't you smarter
you're not a vampire dumb [__] see
a wolf oh set your sorry ass up one
of those fake fangs there's a human
no no just a human damn familiars why
aren't you smarter you dumb [__]
a cabin tonight he's human getting Reckless blade
killing vampires clean the ash don't
leave in the heavens by except the ash
what's this new delivery system for your
syrup it's an effervescent inhaler just
bite down on the mouth guard
delivery is automatic some
friends of mine made it they're also
good with Exposition now apparently
array okay we've got a lead let's go to
playing Wilson time to take these Cowboys
down Cowboys let's go let's do a buddy cop
movie what's he been doing God is feeling
been through five of them so far he allowed
us to take him in I'm gonna go in yeah you are
oh yeah black lights hats now do you know
the blade comics like is Danica Talos or
whatever her name was somebody to know
couldn't tell you comment below people
she's actually a scroll she's related
to Telos the scroll whoa whoa oh
that's like Sauron and a baby with a Reaper yes
you shouldn't have worked with
me what oh no way Dominic Purcell
Prison Break let's go do this the world's changed
since your time the humans have a new Hunter
and you'd like me to kill him wouldn't you yeah
it'd be nice I've interviewed him several times
really yeah he's awesome oh shouts out he
watches this channel certainly he doesn't
remember any of his roles ever nothing
it's good every roll is a fresh slate yes
now it's not just vampires we've got to worry
about we're going to have to take on the rest
of the world too now take on your Public
Image I've been doing this since before
you were born blade you're like a son to me
I'm sorry I got old on you I see you alone
surrounded by enemies we can't win this war
alone yeah but who can you trust us that's
true we would be good vampire Hunters well
it looks like we got ourselves a combo meal
so let's serenade them with drums they're gonna
try to eat the baby yeah man gotta get that fresh
blood chicky yeah don't you turn around when
you were getting cat called Barrel on through
I want a mask like that I feel like
more people should do blade costumes
for Halloween not just play the character
but all the characters it's just every
yeah get like a group of 20 people and
dress all as The prominent figures yeah
walk around with this loaf of bread
you'll be a hit at the party aprily
[Music]
of course it's the X Games vampires
[Music] do you think this is
foreshadowing because he looks
like Justin Timberlake what garlic yes [Music]
I wonder if there's a shortage of just
jars of powdered garlic in the city yeah
staked in the nuts but what is she
she's Jessica freaking bill that's
what she is she's Buffy bro she kind of
looks like Faith just because he's got
Eliza Dushku thing Eliza Dushku
in the house again [Music] ah
Wowie [Music] what is that
it's a lightsaber dude you
never saw one of course might be
pretty much this hurts chica yeah
it did hurt what is it what you're worried
about oh no people have done followed us
let's go let's go let's go
no sometimes the way this
is edited makes you feel like very
panicky yeah it's very kinetic yeah
like different angle angle angle angle
yeah lots and lots of coverage I like
that I'm using layman terms and then
you're making it elevated and nice I'm
here to translate for the cine files okay
[Music] ah no I can't do that to my boy
go take that little [__]
oh I think I kill my man again not
this early move a finger in your
debt I was about this one he's got
something in his hand get up blade
get every angle jump don't you don't
shoot I want them alive [Music]
no I don't like a defeated blade yeah you look
so sad I know acting that's right blade took a
class special agents Ray Cumberland Wilson Hale
FBI we've been tracking you a long time Whistler
dead no no he's not right I don't know I hope
not so how many people have you killed blade
30 40 50 60 70 80 90. 1182. wow my name
is Dr Vance I've been charged with giving
you a psychiatric evaluation would you mind
giving us just a couple of minutes alone he
looks like a superhero and a red shirt yeah
that should be his new outfit with a big old
B on the chest like to look like a superhero
and a t-shirt can you tell me what day it is
how about the president do you know
who's in the white house right now
what year is this 2004 vampires what can you
tell me about that they exist are you one of
them when you drink blood do you feel yourself
becoming sexually aroused but and I'm wondering
what your relationship was like with your
mother yeah good question let's go Freud
was it to be very close oh we
know what happened he's psychotic
Hospital something to keep you compliant and
the usual dose for this sort of thing is two
300 milligrams but I think with a kick
it up to a couple thousand you don't have
a problem with needles do you again how
many neck injections happen in real life
I mean you've had a lot of help today
it's the end game played we're
at the end game now relax
damn it they're all corrupt was that the same
guy's tattoo we just saw or the other ones no
it's the other guy too they were in coats both
the cops and the psych well like the chief
and the psych guy at least yeah the superior
officer but one of the cops isn't I think the
two cops we saw are not like the two actually
brought him in the one guy above them is yeah
this is go the guy with the pony I keep I think I
can't place how I know him but I do yeah it looks
familiar you're all alone blade No One's Gonna
help you now why would they take him out of his
what are you an idiot oh
wow
eating ladies [Music] Hannibal King
I did not realize this was coming
wow
yeah stretch it out totally
[Music]
go okay [Music] so were those maybe
silver restraints or whatever or
how did he get his powers back just now it
was that respiratory oh that thing oh yeah
yeah that's what he's biting on I was like what
that the friend made you know friends [Music]
like they got a second to do a badass slow
walk now we get a hallway fight [Music]
Reynolds look very or 2000s with that
spiky hair yeah and that beard [Music]
what daughter Whistler is that what
you got from that that's yeah [Music]
got like a wrestler or something I thought
he was asking which way Whistler was
I can't shoot around corners I can [Music]
sick [Music] yes ricocheted Arrow
[Music] first hahaha [Music]
yes do you think senior whistler's dead uh uh 50
50. oh my God that's not a good answer I think
he's been dead once so he could come back but I
feel like we didn't see him die yeah exactly oh
all right
I had to read the evidence Locker
for my gear who the hell are you
people my name is Handel King and
this little Hellion right here is
Afghan whistler's daughter Exposition
can't believe that I I needed that sure
you didn't it was a weak moment of mine it's
all good we all have weaknesses that's why an
exec had them put that in the movie this is Hedges
some field inhaler of yours that's Natasha Leone
I didn't see it the runt you saw earlier that was
Summerfield's daughter Zoe damn we call ourselves
the night stalkers so I was like rejects from a
Saturday morning cartoon real rejects your kids
you're not ready to roll with this look at
the way you dressed but that's supposed to
be tactical they broke you out you think this
is a joke you think this is a [__] sitcom
that's just rude I'm pretty sure we
saved your ass back there I'm impressed
like it or not we are all you got the
hell makes you think you know about
hunting vampires is for starters I used to
be one wowie you know the kind of woman that
just screams trouble is here and every
morning Bell in your brain starts going
off but you still managed to ask for her
number but that's all I ever hook up with
she blew them all away in the
[__] storm sweepstakes her
name is Danica Talos and unlike typical
vampires her fangs are located nervous
I've seen that movie too first movie me and Greg
watched on Netflix way back in the day we need to
pull our resources blade he's come back take a
look at this this is really Dracula Dracula is
only one of the names he's gone by the Babylonians
worshiped him as Dagon and now they call him Drake
now they call him champagne poppy he was the first
of his kind the patriarch of hominis nocturna
scientific name they found him in Iraq
about six months ago and he was pissed
this is a weird facial hair look for
Ryan Reynolds yeah it's so like sculpted
llama deep you yeah I gotta get more of
those shirts what's with the Vampire and
cross thing you mean them being like warded
off by crossover he's wearing a cross and
vampires and Crosses I feel like yeah I mean
this in this universe I don't think it does
anything so it's like you know it's a good
way to kind of give some attitude but also
blend in you know you sell vampire merchandise
yeah look around we might have a few things
what you want to kiss me
pretty boy is that you do that
so I'm like whoa weird slightly
homophobic comments in this movie yeah
see nowadays that guy would just be
serious he'd just be like you want
a kiss like I'll do it yeah you know and
then otherwise the other one like my old
really solid we need a new tactic like what a
biological weapon yeah yes oh my God she's a
baby yeah for the last year I've been working
with synthesized DNA in order to create an
artificial virus targeted specifically of vampires
so what's been holding you back we need Dracula's
blood of course you do UV Arc the two points
are connected by a powerful UV laser yes yup
have you ever been laid many times with ladies
I can't take Ryan Reynolds seriously sometimes
he's so what are you talking about he's so
believable he's amazing but he's hysterical
oh
whoa very stylized yep split screen swipe
split screen it's like a comic book please
I swear is that Evan Moss or no hello this is Dr
Vance you page me it's for you yeah go ahead hello
you know at some point you might want to consider
sitting down with somebody kick back get in touch
with your inner child that sort of thing you
might want to consider blinking once in a while
how does he know he's not blinking
I know he's got the shades like
and who needs to Blink when you got the shades
like why have I never seen anybody dressed as
Jessica Beale in Blade three for Halloween
you know what yours should be the first
[Music]
I'm sorry but you can't see Dr Vance right now
no all right Vance what the hell do you
know oh Jesus it's him Abby it's Drake
shift in
I can't get over his name is Drake I know I had a
feeling about you just shoot him go
ahead blade show me what you made oh
nice if you could shape-shift into
somebody for a day who would it be ooh
um see I was shapeshifter the Wesley Snipes
Man spent my day being the coolest dude alive
foreign
[Music]
I do appreciate the sheer amount of
Destruction in this Chase yeah so many
casualties it's just Kool-Aid
Manning through this building
[Music]
oh
interesting stairwell white looking up red looking
down do you think babies have sweeter blood
definitely it's not been tainted by life
careful day Walker why'd you kill fans it
all lived his purpose he died a good death
I wouldn't know anything about that you will
do you think they could ever grasp what it
means to be immortal you're not immortal
I must have heard hundreds of you rodents
make the same claim each one of them has
tasted the end of my sword but I think it is more
likely the next time we meet you far before mine
I was fighting words
what a dad it's gonna sting a little really
[Music] oh geez the bubbling though that
did look painful we're successful say we
wipe out all the vampires want that huh
and somehow I don't picture you teaching
karate at the local y oh dude I would love that
karate at the local y he hates me doesn't he
don't believe whistler's dead
why do you do that sad card yes
she got a line because there's something
bad inside of me why can't you just be nice
their question because the world isn't nice Fair
answer I wish he was just like I never thought of
that before genetic sequencing enzymes you want
a party favor yeah silver hollow points done
do you want a party favor yeah that that UV you
know bow thing that's half as hard as the sun done
what are you doing here talk
talk oh
spill it you know what we're doing what's inside
whoa no what's behind door number one I can't tell
you they'll kill me kill you brother I'll kill you
[Laughter] I do like the blades a
little more loose in this movie yeah
like of everyone getting cool guy dialogue
his is my favorite whoa got Jim Morrison
whoa oh this is crazy it's like daybreakers
again why kill your prey when you can keep
them alive under optimal conditions a donor can
generate anywhere from 50 to 100 pints of blood
productive oh at any given time there's what two
three million homeless wandering around America
oh are they aware do they feel anything they're
in a chemical induced coma a brain dead they
are experiencing nothingness Oblivion they're
going to win can't you see that just come back
there's nothing stopping them now that's me yeah
absolutely there's you you've got 20 seconds
20. [Laughter] cool I loved that moment
foreign [Music]
we'll see they must have a contingency
or we won't see maybe it's just
sad oh she is blind okay [Music]
there you go Patton whoa I knew it I wouldn't let
it go and I knew it but is he I don't know about
that changed very possibly he's the villain now or
did he shape-shift into him that's what's going on
hello dude you're dead [Music]
started from the bottom now we're here
guys do not kill Natasha Leone
no
no we'd only just met
[Music]
no don't worry she'll restart the day over again
sweet birthday baby groundhog say it's
a Russian doll reference Roxanne oh
[Music]
his fingers stretching that was
gnarly yeah those Nosferatu fingers
nowadays shouting King just you
know is just like a joke Zoe
no don't fall for it I don't
know of course he's calling her
that's what happened to me at the beginning
could that be you ask your doctor
for immortality is right for you
AstraZeneca oh no oh poor thing where's
the daughter this is very the joker-esque
sure trying to torture him use it what like the
pain or yeah channel that rage channel to hurt
yes
scream it out oh dog's a vampire
I think that was true that was the thing yeah
importing the vampire genius other species
experimenting you made a god vampire Pomeranian
Vamp Pomeranian vampiranian Vamp precious
enemy well that depends who you ask because
clearly this dog has a bigger dick than you
and when the [__] did you see my
face that is the best response to that
it looks like he could be Wolverine right now
yeah look at that Marvel bod right there I know
what would hurt you more than anything
oh ow you don't want to go back to being
one of us do you because we could really
use a go-getter Like You on the team on
the team that's right I'm going to watch
when you become a vampire do you just get a tattoo
there must be somebody there somebody from the
family is like yeah we gotta Mark you up bring the
little girl in here for human beat on jeez [Music]
is that 240 frames per second it says FPS Force
per shot I don't know hey that's actually maybe
not bad that's that might be what it is much
colder I'll be your driver this evening okay
intense what if this was entirely scored by
Drake that would be that would be something
else if you're watching this I'm already dead
oh my I want you to promise me that you'll take
care of her okay I've been reading her the
Oz books every night we just started reading
the Emerald City of Oz you know the one with
the known King oh yes King as a precaution I
transmitted the genetic sequence to colder in case
our main stock was destroyed you're gonna need to
infuse it with Drake's blood every vampire in the
immediate vicinity should die almost instantly
good you need to know there's a chance of ours
could destroy you too I'm not sure if your immune
system will be able to tolerate it I'm sorry we
just didn't have enough time to properly test it
when did you make this video like an hour
ago before she went to go find I guess it's
gonna be shot from one of the four battle
rifles you must be sure that the shot counts
Chris hired all is I don't know who that is he's a
great character actor too he pops up in all sorts
of stuff he looks familiar but I don't know the
name do you want to die yes I'm Not Afraid yes
yes you will love her spit on him what if
you could remain a child forever wouldn't you
like that that would suck interesting what age
would you want to be stuck at forever good one
eight I don't know time of Innocence before all
this mess no drugs I'm like 8 or 22. pick one
[Music]
yeah suit up
Boomerang knife let's take it
back to the concrete streets
synchronize bike riding look at that Jessica
bieloki is a great action star I'm here for ya
sniffy little tracking now it's surgically
implanted in your body you see when one of
us goes missing the others they just dial
up the satellite which is in space oh
instant Cavalry after you know a few hours
did you see that tickle that you're feeling
in the back of your throat right now
oh that's atomized colloidal silver oh
it's being pumped through the building's air
conditioning system you juggling Thunder wowie
whoa Dragon fat lady should
be singing right about now
Drake's doing a collab do you have a cell phone
foreign
yo ripped she's auditioning for Tomb
Raider right now yeah and the part's hers
sure dude she worked out for
this look at his arms hell yeah
that's right you should have been flexing this
whole time take us to the gun show Roxanne
oh geez
nice I wanna boot knife
it's okay stunt team guy you
got your featured moments
we've been waiting it's the sickest you okay
oh nice
me
oh yeah now it's me sideways now it's Resident
Evil oh he's a cute little guy aren't you sideways
what a shock this is a weird term
also yes aren't you usually sideways
often often times I guess not always but
often they framed him through that dog's
legs me standing up like that would be the Rarity
yeah yeah or upside down upside down difficult
wow nicely done Chris Redfield
sorry Resident Evil jokes okay
awesome seen my dog have you
tried the lobby oh ready to die
I was born ready mother yeah
sometimes his head went back with no punch yeah
where's Jessica Biel with the kid she'll
step in and like save him at a crucial moment
people ever get into fights like
this in real life I feel like a
lot of real life fist fights very
short yeah and not very stylish
come on man Vanquish the six God
oh King
it's killing me where he's from yeah
he looks so familiar oh twofer [Music]
saw a movie now whoa
this is cool death should
have done that earlier yeah
let's wake you up [Music]
kind of a weird moment but I'm into it
wow
oh no
thank you oh yeah if you're
reading this it's too late
[Music]
take him out take him out take him out
God's plan
he caught it
grab it please oh
oh
yeah yeah damn
little tiny little platelets floating up into
the sky that's wild looking yeah but is it
gonna kill blade yep definitely that's why the
franchise ended after this terrific final send-off
foreign
if you're breathing this it's too
late that would have been a better
Drake joke give it up King she said
give it up King go off go off King
no no Parker Posey I don't need to survive
the future of our race rests with you
uh-huh sinner or later thirst
what a line
bring the big sigh of relief blade
what if the Vampire part of him died
but the human part lives that'd be an
interesting turn of events and then blade
finally gets to retire and raise little Zoe
blade four yeah blade and Zoe yeah and
then it'll be like Batman Beyond where
it's like old man blade and then Zoe's
out hunting vampires some logan-ish yeah
you idiot yeah what good are you FBI
couldn't even track down a hive of Vamps
Federal Bureau of idiots yep
the tickets
certain jacket off or was that Drake and Drake's
final gift let's just say the FBI got their body
got their mixtape just wasn't the one
they were banking on oh that's why he
had no shirts that's why he had no shirt it was
all there incredible that was cool You Drake
thank you six God blade was still out
there somewhere his life was a war
and everybody knows the war never ends
nice shot [Music] okay written
and directed by David S goyer
okay damn man I wonder what happened to
them I don't know nice cool credit medley
oh the Rizza did coded the music that's neat
that's kind of cool felt like a very hip score
it's even hipper when you say it I
know especially in that white guy voice
I appreciate they made these credits a music
video so is the Trinity blade Jessica Biel
and Ryan Reynolds that's right the definitive
Trinity or is it the Pomeranian yeah the two
dogs it was those three dogs yeah totally
and they get this like Christopher Guest
starter pack on loan Triple H he was a wrestler
there you go obviously Triple H idiot idiot
I can't believe that yeah I figured it had to be
yeah like I was like no no this guy oh my God take
away my [__] card for anything ever yeah you
failed this way let the records show how badly you
have that wasn't down the road you're off my team
Roxy I [__] with Triple H sure how could you not
recognize him in this start making performance he
looks pretty much the same now too with his hair
back like that wow yeah [__] Triple H that's
crazy that I didn't pick up on that that is
King nuts it's okay we just watched The Watcher
boy for the first time and The Big Show is in
that and uh I know I know this guy I know I know
him oh my God you guys at home must have been
screaming at me every time I was like um I know
him that's yeah those angry comments man you're
gonna be you'll never forget Triple H's face holy
[__] after this damn man I just did Triple H
did Roxanne I hope you are prepared to do a bad
apology I do feel like I did that I didn't I could
have made a lot more Drake references anytime I'm
feeling like a failure yeah totally 100 every time
we've talked about like uh in life not just me
and you but people right you talk about Cena you
talk about the rock you talk about Batista um
Sasha Banks like anybody because of Becky Lynch
Ronda Rousey is in a movie or two totally um and
Triple H I feel like many times people have said
yeah played three and I just never like put the
pieces together Kane was in see no evil nor did
I but he's in it he's a couple of those movies
damn I'm so so bummed with myself right now Hulk
Hogan also did a bunch of movies yeah Stone Cold
Steve Austin yeah well what did you think of the
film what did you think of Blade Trinity I
thought it was solid really okay I thought
I think it wasn't it was my least favorite
of the three um and there was moments that
are not solid but overall I think because I had
such low expectations going in I totally think
it's serviceable yeah it's fun like it's it's
cheesy and it doesn't have nearly the flow and
the mood that the first two do but I'm not gonna
pretend like I didn't just have fun right now I
mean right I'll put on the first two way sooner
than I'll re-watch this it's not egregious though
it's not like you're watching it and you hate
watching it and you're like oh this is sucks
it's like it definitely it's it's okay yeah it
definitely feels like somebody's like I feel bad
for David go here saying this but it felt like
some producer's nephew wrote the script because
just like the dialogue is is just so much the
dialogue's tough is just like everyone's talking
like a cool guy and swearing and interesting
and creative ways that I feel like are very
much aimed at like a high school audience
yeah and it was some of the editing choices
were challenging too it's like very jarring at
times but I still love blade as a character oh
yeah I'll watch them all day and I really like
Jessica Biel and this and I like I think it was
fun to have her and Ryan Reynolds and kind of
play off each other like there's parts that are
silly work for me because it was enjoyable uh
and I still think like the costume design sick
you know there's stuff there are elements that
I'm like yeah that really works yeah like it's
always a joy to watch Wesley Snipes we got a
little bit with the word it just says a word oh
god post credits
[Music]
blade will return is Blade the originator of
the post-credit scene very first post-credits
scene we should go back and film it 2004.
so this is a 113 minutes it definitely felt
longer than that to me this felt like a two
and a half hour movie it did drag at times
um horror drama gritty intense yeah I don't know
about the horror part I would put cheesy yeah into
the like this one has the most defined element of
Camp I feel like this honestly like though this is
nearly a two-hour movie and though it does in some
ways feel longer than that uh it also felt like I
was watching like an episode of a blade TV show
and I know there is a blade TV show people have
mentioned but uh you know anime is live action
it was like a one one season show different guy
um I don't know anything about that but but
watching this I was like this does feel like
this got adapted for TV and now I'm watching
like a pilot that somehow they were allowed
to do a lot of wearing throughout but like even
a lot of the violence and and the gore gags and
stuff were like a lot less like this felt like
a PG-13 movie with an R-rated dialogue pass well
there was a lot I mean I I swear every other word
but this movie really swore every other word this
movie reminded me of your friend in high school
who just like wants to say the most outlandish
swear word salad combinations just because they
want to come off as like cool as possible like
that's the thing it's like the Ryan Reynolds
character feels like you know every teenage
guy's fantasy like when you're 13 and you're
drawing like anime characters and you're like
yeah this is my cool guy you know you literally
asked at one point cool beard and he's got the
spiky hair and and you know he's always got an
attitude and a quip in the chamber you know yeah
you said did Ryan Reynolds write his own dialogue
and I was like oh no that means that John cannot
be enjoying it no I was enjoying it but it was
that thing where like looking back over so many
years this is before Ryan Reynolds was like the
brand that he is now and yet even back then it
feels like he's doing his Ryan Reynolds thing
right like you know it's it's toned down like
three to five percent from where it is now
but like yeah I mean he's pretty much just
doing his attitude and his you know thing that
he brings to a movie so like I I think I expected
you know it's like when you see you know somebody
with a really high profile earlier on in their
career you know you see them before the Persona
is developed or is here I was like oh this feels
pretty much like seeing him in X-Men Origins or
Deadpool or any number of other things did you
watch two guys a girl on a pizza place no what is
that oh okay two guys a girl on a pizza place is a
TV show that Ryan Reynolds starred in I'm gonna
say in the late 90s that I was obsessed with
um and he was this was two guys a girl in a pizza
place to me just like with a different beard I
mean sure I'm telling you two guys a girl in a
pizza place 98 1998. oh wow um vintage Reynolds
yeah it was it's the first time I ever saw him
and I grew up on Ryan Reynolds and then later
on I think that's one of the first things that he
ever did but it kind of reminded me he was very
goofy in that and he was very goofy in this well
yeah I I remember like yeah this is the earliest
probably action role now I've seen for him because
I'm yeah like back in the day I was used to the
idea of him as like Van Wilder or various other
comedic roles yeah at raunchy comedies yeah yeah
I definitely feel you I mean I think that he
is just so great I watched this year welcome
to wrexham which is he bought the soccer team
and it was the doc about him buying the soccer
team in Rob mceleney mclarney however he say it
from Ollie sunny it's always sunny yeah Mac yes
um and I think that he is I think Ryan Reynolds is
truly like unbelievably dynamic as a human and as
a performer but it was a little jarring in this
movie The juxtaposition of him and blade like it
just felt like they were in two different even
Jessica Biel like Jessica Biel and blade were in
one movie yeah and Natasha Leon was in one movie
yeah and then Ryan Reynolds and sometimes that's
life you know sometimes characters in life is like
what room do you think you're in so it's not like
it never would happen but it was very like this
is the Ryan Reynolds show but um yeah totally like
they it feels like they let him walk around and do
improv and stuff like that and I and I don't know
what the vibe would have been if that was like his
thing or if the director if David goyer was just
like yes go this is gold let's get it yeah um I
mean yeah and that gives it a certain additional
I guess like comic bookiness because again all the
dialogue is kind of like that but this one like
you know I I appreciate across all these movies
that you have you know blade is this sort of
singular figure he's got Whistler to some extent
and the twistler in this yeah I did too like I was
sad that he left so early and I get that they got
a set up uh uh what's her name Ally or whatever
Abby Abby the daughter yeah but at the same time I
was sad that he had to completely depart in order
for that to happen and and I think that they could
have done a lot more with the emotionality of that
I mean not that again this is trying to be a drama
and this movie I think out of all of them is the
least concerned with those kinds of Storytelling
flourishes but I would have liked some kind of
mourning or just some kind of more emotional
send-off for Whistler or I don't know like yeah we
don't really know because yeah it's like it looked
like he died but we didn't see it so nowadays
especially that usually means nobody's dead and
for his daughter it's like yeah you have that like
shower scene you have a couple moments but
like she just lost her father from whom she
probably had like an odd relationship given you
know his life of vampire fighting and and their
whole traumatic experience from the backstory
and everything so like it would have been I
feel like nice to commemorate that somehow uh
but yeah like these movies all have like a fun
Dynamic of like it's blade and Whistler and then
you've got like a colorful cast of like additional
semi-allies he's got to work with and that creates
like a fun friction dynamic between them and then
you know whoever the new super Vamp monster is
like it has all the ingredients of a blade movie
uh and it's certainly like clipped along but it's
not as stylish like there's a lot of stuff that's
like hyper edited and just like tons of cover like
there are a couple fights I thought that nicely
still accentuated or attempted to accentuate you
know Wesley snipes's motion especially you know
his prowess is a martial artist but there's a lot
of stuff in here that uh feels a little bit like a
like an editing salad you know and that also kind
of reminded me of a TV show because you have way
less time to shoot all that stuff so oftentimes
you'll just have a lot of Wick pans and a lot
of Quick Cuts um which you know it wasn't full on
that here but it certainly was like the the least
uh Punchy in terms of the action not that I didn't
like some of like his uh his retractable like
um the knife on the lead I thought was kind of a
neat thing he got to use the boomerang knife once
they have all these crazy ass gadgets but even
that was like all right we got our crazy gadgets
and here's our like Montage of like showing off
the gadgets and stuff this this just felt like
uh like a bunch of modular elements being plugged
in rather than a story that went from beginning
to end you're colder on this than I am it was fun
but it has like way more like I can easily see how
this is a drop off would you say this is a c for
you yeah maybe like a c I might put a Plus on it
for enjoyability because again I was never annoyed
I was never bored I was never upset by anything I
was just like after the first two it was average
true yeah it was it was pretty I feel like mid
would be like kind of a mean thing to say about
it but yeah it was kind of average it was it was
it was fun enough but after the first two you know
clearly we've seen how it can be way better and
not feel uh quite so I don't know it just felt
like it was like just chop chop moving along
and they have so many interesting characters and I
was like oh cool Parker Posey holding it down for
part threes of horror franchises here and like I
liked why what what part three did Parker Posey do
scream three oh pretty uh famous like Parker Posey
turn from uh she wants to come back to scream and
uh yeah yeah yeah I'm here for it but it's like
you've got them and they're kind of characters
but then you've got Drake and Drake is kind of
you know he is the big bad but I feel like both
of them kind of get shuffled around and slightly
diminished by just like the overall structure of
the movie is Drake the best you ever had yourself
of course always yes I'm waiting for that for two
hours oh it's okay it's honestly never mind
it's okay try it I'm like I'm I'm running out
the road I don't have the biggest Drake lexicons
running through all my okay really good really it
actually was interesting that they didn't name him
Drake though and that they did have a character
King like things that at the time they never know
would be distracting but in 2023 it's unbelievably
distracting to have one character named Drake and
one character named King yeah it just was like
yeah every time the king thing you and I had to
hold back laughter and it's like that they never
could have predicted that that would turn into
what it did but it's like get up King and I'm like
yeah [Music] like that worked out I think like I
think that appreciated and valuable as opposed to
Drake yeah where it's like yeah Drake you're just
thinking about Drake and I liked I mean I liked
that lore element of like ah you know Dracula he's
taking many forms and they do that thing of like
oh you know some of the lore he doesn't turn into
mist but he could shape-shift and he's been called
many things and now it's been sanded down by time
to where he's called Drake now and he's got this
crazy form and like I liked all that stuff
it's like this is a movie where I I I had fun
but I can easily see how you could take everything
that they had at their disposal and make a much
better version yes I hear you because do you had
all the the daybreakers thing where you have all
the people in the blood bags the like the homeless
folks that they are harvesting and I was like
that's an interesting idea we should explore oh no
that's just kind of like a neat set piece and then
we leave there and we don't really think about it
again and even like the science stuff was like as
neat I liked having it uh you know this whole like
we've developed a new you know poison and if we
can just get you know Dracula's blood we can wipe
them all out or at least all of them near here um
you know things like that are cool it's just like
nothing ever really like immerses you far enough
to you feel or that I felt like the true weight or
the stakes like everything kind of breezed by and
it felt much lighter and much more like a uh like
a just a you know a chapter it felt like a episode
of like episodic TV where like everything's gonna
reset next week whereas the first two feel like
they flow from one to the other I definitely feel
that even with the post-credits scene where it's
like yeah more to come for you does it go one
two three probably I too I liked a lot like
I think yeah probably one just because it has a
bit more of the breathing space and more of the
um I don't know yeah you never forget your first
it's got all those iconic moments it's got a nice
sort of breath to the tone while also having all
the action um the second one though I still think
is really imaginative and fun and action-packed
but yeah I guess for that little extra ounce
of like tone and story oomph I would put one at
the top but some days I might put two at the top
but you know it's like one two and then
you know leave a space and then three
I'm like three I like significantly less but
it's still fun like if I I wouldn't go out of
my way not to buy the three pack if that was the
choice yeah yeah you know because yeah I really
liked having Jessica Beale and I thought she it's
weird it's like it's fun having both her and Ryan
Reynolds Ryan Reynolds is fun to watch for the you
know the like Cinema anthropology of it yeah he is
um but you know he's in his own movie
he's doing his own thing he's you know
the kind of Center Point from where all this
high school kid dialogue is coming from and
everybody too the king thing and the Drake
thing like it's another one of those where
like everyone's got a cool name and everyone
calls everyone by name all the time and I'm
like it's cool when people call blade blade
all the time but when you're when everyone's
like hey King what's going on King you think
you you think you're better than us kingsler
Whistler yeah I'm like okay clearly you think
these are very cool names and this this movie
just feels like a guy trying to be super cool and
he's only happy Joe he's got the cool jacket but
clearly you can tell he's trying way too hard to
be cool just the whole movie not Ryan Reynolds
specifically but like I'm devastated about the
Triple H lack of knowledge that I just displayed
put some respect on Triple H's name bro and I mean
stuff like that like I love that they included him
and I and I like that he at least gets to be a
prominent Hench character but I feel like even
in a previous blade movie it's like I think back
to having Donald Logan the first one he's just a
Hench but he's like prominent you don't really
ever forget about him he's got a good amount
of personality and I liked what Triple H did
here but I was like man you know in a slightly
different movie he might have had even more to
do or or Parker Posey like Parker Posey I really
liked I thought she was gonna be the I thought she
was going to be the big bad at the beginning and
then she just kind of gets lost so I'm like yeah
there's a big chunk without her where I was like
huh yeah I thought that it was Dominic Purcell
like I thought it was Parker Posey big bad then
Dominic but then it totally yeah once he's Dracula
you're like oh yeah yeah totally um but yeah it's
like I liked her presence and I liked her look
and Vibe and and and I think there is something
to the campiness that they went for with this
movie that could have worked in a more like
uh in in a way where I'm not asterisking so hard
it's like again I enjoyed it but whereas like I
feel like there's a version where I'm like I love
the cheesiness because you know not in spite of
I'm not trying to shoehorn this into every review
we do although I am but do you know I feel like
this movie needed any little romance I Need A
Little Romance it could have used I'm not I'm
not effing around guys I get whereas blade one and
Blade Two didn't have as much room for it don't
you feel like this movie had room for it either
between um Ryan Reynolds and and uh Jessica Biel
or blade and Jessica Biel or Natasha Leone and
Jessica I'll take that one any version of that
or even Parker Posey and Dominic Purcell like
there's just there was room for there was room
for sexy Dad yeah don't tell me you couldn't have
made out in this movie not at all Yeah well yeah
you're gonna give me three you're gonna give me
a vampire Trilogy with no [__] at all I think
that's egregious it is a little bit and I know
and I read all your comments and I love you guys
and you're just like why is Roxy lover of Love
shippers ships cause I am cause I am yeah and
it's a Hallmark of the genre I'll give it to you
I mean blood the next sexiness make out take your
shirts off I mean I would even get some shirtless
stuff we got a lot of shirtless stuff jeez I mean
we got shirtless Dominic Purcell which I feel
like he only got bigger after this oh he only
got more jacked but uh Ryan Reynolds man that was
like oh I didn't expect you to be so buff in this
movie and then we got a shirtless Blaze shirtless
blade absolutely I mean you know the coolest guy
ever that's the thing it's like I I would have
even settled for one of those like the the first
movie and the second movie with blade kind of have
more so the second even have this thing where yeah
you have this sort of main supporting female lead
and you're like oh is there is there something
there maybe a little bit and and it doesn't ever
really come to fruition or anything but that makes
sense given what the stories are I could have
done something like that because like I would
be a little conflicted if it's like okay Blade's
gonna get with whistler's daughter but uh I hear
you I hear you there could be some kind of latent
magnetism though and that's a neat little Nuance I
think the previous two have that's kind of unique
whereas yeah here there's not really any of that
or yeah you could have Parker Posey like trying to
live up to Dracula or trying to please him trying
to you know be his you know right hand and and you
know and Sharon you know Eternal decadent love and
blood and all that stuff yeah like just a lot of
opportunities thank you thank you sure absolutely
um and yeah stamps like to Bone they do they're
all about it and it's a lust thing sure we didn't
even see the dogs boning you don't think
Vamp dogs are gonna be humping each other
I'm not saying I want to see that I'm just
saying there's so much editing on this review
it's okay it's okay it's okay just uh
just just less uh direct terminology bone
fairer I guess it's all contact YouTube's
getting smarter about context what can I call it
passionate love me yeah oh it feels worse yeah
nothing gets people drippy moist like some
passionate love making but like this is it's also
one of those that you have so many great elements
and you have a great Ensemble a lot of character
actors and yeah like you get a patent Oswald he
he was he was making it he was in it he had but
he had uh at least you know made love made sweet
love a couple times established it was represented
to women somewhere yes he specified which got you
know no need to be insecure man we all go through
phases yeah there were a couple moments where I
was just like this does feel very 90s not 2000s
the way that they're treating like yeah same sex
whatever it is sure yeah everybody's got to go
out of their way to be like I'm super straight
cool very straight cool and straight yeah yeah
whereas now yeah the fun is is kind of riding the
line to a degree but but yeah it's like I really
liked Jessica Beals presence you know like I don't
think it's a kind of movie that gives her like
a real opportunity to to shine with the material
but I really like your presence I like that she
clearly like put in the work I believed her most
of the time when she was fighting yeah like she
her like at least her arms you see her arms and
like it looks like she really worked out like she
got kind of built for this and I love I love when
people especially actresses like to throw down for
that because I think there's often that pressure
to be like still be dainty but also Kick-Ass
and I'm like no if you're gonna be kicking ass
like look like you practiced a little bit to kick
ass and I told her that they had her in that mode
here like yeah if in in the hands of the folks
who had made the previous films I would have
loved to have seen that character because that's
another cool opportunity whistler's daughter new
addition to the team New Generation it's a Trope
but it's also something that I think would work
really nicely Works decently here but yeah just
he could have been richer any world in which we
would see her again I mean now with the Multiverse
and all that stuff I mean who knows because she is
the way I thought I doubt it but it was possible
the way I felt about her and this is how I feel
about Emily Blunt and Edge of Tomorrow where it's
just like I feel like there's you're you're really
really good with the movements yeah I believe
everything every shot every like you really
like you said she bulked up and she just looked a
killer oh yeah like I I not no slight to her and
I I liked her a lot in Texas Chainsaw as well
that remake but like it's one of those casting
choices at this moment in time where you're like
okay this could easily be just sort of like here's
your catapults we're gonna try and get you into
movies now from TV and not to say that I had like
a low expectation or any particular expectation
but yeah after you know the movie finished I was
like yeah she really showed up to this and like
she is as much as I think Ryan Reynolds Shirley
probably gets the attention for this movie in
terms of Supporting Cast like I thought she
held it down with what she was given I would be
happy to see that character again and that rapport
with blade again I was bummed about Natasha Leone
like because I thought yeah it's she's got nice
presents I like the character they developed her
and her daughter it's just so brief you know it's
like I could have done with a little bit you could
have introduced like this whole team in ways that
actually make us care about them so that once
everything happens later and it's not just oh
he's got a kid that's a bad thing to do we gotta
stop him you know yeah definitely yeah this entire
Trilogy had a lot of Natasha Leone so like it had
so just I'm thinking back to the second one with
um our our dude from Walking Dead yeah um you know
just Norman Reedus thank you just people that you
wouldn't expect that or that I didn't even know
like I didn't know that Ryan Reynolds and Jessica
Biel were in this I didn't know I didn't know
anybody was in these movies at all and every movie
I feel like you and I were like whoa that person
that person Triple H I'm gonna be kicking myself
about the next 10 years okay forgive yourself that
happens to the best of us I can't it's all good
I know when that hotline bling that can mean it
could only mean one thing more Drake preferences
oh that's a recycled one from earlier um but yeah
really good not not not great not terrible okay
solid is is fun I had fun yeah I don't know
if I would even I don't know if I would even
go so far as to call it solid okay that's me I
I'm allowed to say so absolutely I'm glad you
thought it was solid I'm sorry that you did it's
a solid experience it's weird it's not the word
I would go for because I think it is like kind
of a weird medley of moments and it's just yeah
it's it's just not as expert not as graceful not
as you're right it's not consistent so solid you
would think it'd be like a consistent I think more
like to me the medium is the the average is solid
yeah like when you combine the highs and lows and
divide it's solid sure yeah I can see that it's
like I feel like everything was there you know
they had everything they needed for greatness
I think this they got me with enjoyability at the
very least you know good yeah I'll take that is
there anything we miss is there anything else you
wanna you wanna touch upon try everything you're
feeling particularly passionate about I don't know
yeah this is fun it's fine yeah Dominic Purcell
good to see you good to see you all this is
very much yeah this looks like a bunch of people
hopping in from from TV this time I'm gonna miss
Wesley I am too like that's the thing is no matter
what in these movies like he is great and he's a
good core yep you know that's it like this movie
feels the most impersonal in so many respects
because I feel like in some ways it doesn't even
fully you got Ryan Reynolds narrating it doesn't
even fully feel like we're a hundred percent like
I feel like the first two you feel like you're
with Blade the entire way whereas here you're
kind of hopping around to a bunch of stuff in a
way that feels a little less focused I don't know
but uh solid uh Ron joxie it's Ron joxie solid
time at the B Movie exploitation Cinema but
what did you guys think leave us your blade
Trinity thoughts do you love this movie do
you think it's underrated are we slagging off
your favorite Motion Picture let us know oh no
and uh what should we check out next and uh
oh those dogs were kind of neat I like that
they brought back the reaper mouth for the dog I
like a good Palm a good yeah a vampom well guys
pet your Vamps uh kiss your moms and hey
before we get out of here let's do a paper
Mikhail Lyndon McHale lives in Sweden a
word that's right that's right word and
that was the last image or you know before the
post-credits scene you know that was the last
sentiment the movie left us with and if there's
anybody who is good with a word who is eloquent
it's Mikhail Lyndon he's a classy guy and
everybody from Sweden seems to be classy
Sweden's full class dude I I believe that I've
never met a Swedish person that wasn't like very
sweet sweet and Sweet it's just a sweet sweet
totally yeah and the last name Linden what do
you know about Lyndon Johnson oh not a lot you
should enlighten me with your historical prowess
he's a president yeah Lyndon Baines Johnson is
that true yeah Lyndon B should have been oh yeah
the L Beach secretly our favorite Linden is you
oh yeah no no no Lyndon Johnson doesn't hold a
candle to Mikhail Lyndon it doesn't hold him
a candle you basically were saying you should
be president you should be president of Sweden
of Sweden and here yeah or the Prime Minister
whatever your government that setup is and if
you were a vampire you know because you got a
lot of you know older historical you know know
history-rich buildings and architecture and just
you know you're from an older part of the world
so I imagine that you know if anybody our patreon
is likely to have some vampire genes hiding down
somewhere in their uh in their genome it could be
you and uh very true and if anybody was to turn
us I would be honored if it was Mikhail honestly
you know I would let you get get all close and
and bite my neck well Swedish Fish are red and
blood is red but Swedish Fish are apparently
not Swedish according to Mikhail he sent us a
message yes I gotta get back to him directly
this is a this is a good dad joke um because
we're talking about food things where do you know
that french fries aren't made in France they're
made in Greece [Music] that's for you that's for
you Mikhail we love you stay crispy and uh we'll
catch you next month stay pledged and uh yeah
stay sweet I don't think you can help it I mean
you know technology is advancing every day you
can change whatever you want pretty soon you'll
have designer babies why can't you have designer
tomorrow for yourself solid anyway peace buddy